this is a production of cornell
university
so hello i'm uh michael missouri and i
have the
the pleasure of introducing today's a
special seminar speaker
kristen lauria who will be presenting uh
for her master's uh thesis defense
um and so kristin uh actually got her
bachelor's and natural resources
uh here at cornell and from there
uh went on a variety of uh
farming and farm advocacy adventures um
working at uh farm hack among others
um but it was her time at spiro bush
farm that kindled
uh a real love used in today's talk for
for beans and dry beans
um from there she
then went to wisconsin madison uh
for a year working with erwin goldman in
his group there
before uh i was lucky to recruit her
to cornell to do her master's uh
research
uh with me on a vegetable
trialing uh and breeding for sustainable
systems
and is really lucky in kristen's uh
time with us uh not only uh
did she get to do a balance of
many activities from working in
extension
related aspects to pathology
writing trialing and breeding but she
helped us
get started on uh the dry bean breeding
aspects of our research program and
that's going to be something
uh that will look forward to remaining
connected with kristin
for years to come and also will be
reaping the benefits from
those systems that she helped us set up
um and so
i'm very glad to turn it over to the
kristen today
um we'll uh share about her work
in dry beans
okay great thanks michael for that
introduction
um and so i'll be speaking today about
two different projects that revolve
generally around genetic improvement
of dry bean within the context of
regional food systems
so i'll start off with a little bit of
background on driving production
here in the northeast as i suspect many
of you are not
super familiar with this crop and also
some background on common bean diversity
generally
so common bean underwent two parallel
domestications
that continue to define modern market
classes
each gene pool is subdivided into three
races
with distinct adaptive characteristics
originating in contrasting environments
of the center of origin for example
race durango is adapted to hot and arid
environments
while race mesoamerica is adapted to the
humid lowlands of central america
greatly reduced diversity within modern
market classes
compared to broader domesticated gene
pools
has increased has increasingly been
cited as an
obstacle to genetic improvement
particularly in andean germplasm
only some of bean races are represented
by modern market classes
and crossing between gene pools and even
races
is relatively uncommon in modern bean
breeding
due to strict market class definitions
as well as some issues
of autoimmune related hybrid inviability
that occurs between some inter-gene pool
crosses
these factors have limited movement of
adaptive traits between modern market
classes
moving on to some background on driving
production in new york state
though a substantial amount of dried
beans are still grown here
it was once a major crop for our region
with much more widespread production
common bean has been grown in what is
now the northeastern united states
states
since before european settlement and
continues to be an important cultural
and subsistence crop for indigenous
communities
of our region after settlement
new york state was the largest bean
producing state
prior to the 19th century in 1909
115 000 acres were grown on just
over 21 000 farms
just in new york at the time
primarily navy beans which were then
called pea beans
were grown in addition to kidneys yellow
eyes
and a small amount of black turtle there
was also still widespread cultivation of
other traditional varieties
and many different strains of varieties
were grown
in different regions of the state for
unique environments or markets
most modern cultivars have their origins
in these traditional and land race bean
varieties
either associated with indigenous
communities
brought by european settlers or a
combination of the two
varieties brought by european settlers
frequently had their origins in early
colonization of south america
and one hypothesis for how indian
geoplasm from south america
reached the northeast is via early
visitation from europe to north america
other hypotheses have posited that
indium germplasm may have reached north
america via the caribbean
in comparison to that impressive acreage
and number of bean growers
back in 1909 today just
12 619 acres of dry beans
were grown on 91 farms in 2017
in the state of new york this is
compared to
282 000 acres of soybeans
grown on over 2000 farms
this decline has complex economic
demographic
and agronomic causes but has been
attributed in part
to outbreaks of being common mosaic
virus and root rots
in the early 20th century as well as the
rapid expansion
of cheap agricultural land in western
regions
after world war one which was purchased
by soldiers
who supposedly had a newfound taste for
dry beans that they
developed in the military however
it appears that beans may once again be
making a comeback
in new york recent figures demonstrate
increasing production in the state
with 2019 figures representing an
increase
over just 9 600 acres
in 2012. organic production is
increasing faster than conventional
likely result the result of high demand
for organic products generally
and a significant price premium
available for organically grown beans
still the majority of driving production
today
occurs in other regions with the highest
producing states being north dakota
michigan nebraska and minnesota
while washington and idaho have aired
climates reducing some
issues of foliar pathogens that trouble
the northeast
states such as michigan or minnesota
have similar
climate to the northeast resulting in
useful overlap
of breeding priorities and potential for
collaboration
so different production regions across
the united states tend to specialize
in a subset of market classes here in
new york
nearly all acreage is devoted to black
dark red kidney and
light red kidney market classes the
majority of this crop
is sold to a few processors and
subsequently to canneries
which is a highly consolidated industry
here in new york we only have one
cannery left
in angola new york and nearly all
growers
in new york buy certified seed from
western states
which has been an effective strategy in
reducing levels of seedborne disease
canning quality is a trait of top
importance
in commodity dried bean programs due to
the stringent quality requirements
imposed by bean canneries candy
inequality is both a complex trait
and is costly to phenotype and has been
cited
as an obstacle to genetic improvement by
incentivizing narrow crosses
within elite cultivars that already
possess
good canning quality other high priority
traits include yield
upright growth habit and white mold
resistance
as a food legume dry beans are a high
value complement
to small grains forage and fodder
systems that excel
within many environments of the
northeast
more diverse cropping systems have been
shown to increase yields and
profitability particularly in organic
systems
as a source of plant protein dry beans
offer
a tasty nutritious and beautiful source
of sustenance
for consumers breeding and market
development efforts
for small grains have been initiated in
the past 10 years
to explicitly increase demand and reply
rebuild supply chains
for regionally grown grains but parallel
efforts and pulse crops have lagged
behind
while most driving acreage in new york
is still devoted to black and kidney
market classes
some producers and processors are
expanding into market classes
that have not been grown in the state in
recent decades
but that appeared to be well suited for
our production environment
data from 2020 trials at geneva indicate
that such
alternative classes such as great
northern
navy yellow and
not so much cranberry can perform just
as well or better than black or kidney
market classes
due to breeding advancements many of
these market classes which are widely
grown in other reach
regions of the country increase
increasingly
possess an upright indeterminate growth
habit that is required for direct
harvest
a trait that was previously
predominantly limited to black bean
market class
progress in disease resistance breeding
has also improved
performance in temperate regions such as
the northeast
opportunities for increased regional
production include
proximity to population centers of the
east coast
increased consumer interest in buying
local or
regional products and the productivity
of alternative market classes
as shown in preliminary yield trials
however challenges remain such as the
loss
of generational knowledge for producing
dry beans in our region
the loss of many regional processors and
other supply chain actors
the loss of specialized bean equipment
when needed
and also the limited capacity of many
farmers to process or handle dry beans
on their own farms
central to the effort of supporting
regional agriculture
from their perspective of a plant
breeder
is engagement with diverse stakeholder
needs of key actors
in the food system and prioritization of
traits
of importance to each of these actors
some traits of course overlap these
traits
include agronomic traits that are high
priority for growers
culinary and nutritional traits for
consumers
and general food system sustainability
priorities that we all share
such as resource use efficiency and pest
resistance
for example that reduces the need for
chemical controls
notably you may note that this table
does not include
canning quality which as i mentioned is
a difficult trait to breed for and
phenotype for
because a higher percentage of regional
driving sales go to dry packed markets
the ability to de-prioritize canning
quality in favor of other traits
may be a substantial advantage in making
breeding progress
so that wraps up the driving
crash course and
first is a project funded by assaire
graduate student grant to explore
intravarietal diversity
of the jacobs cattle bean within
decentralized seed saving networks
jacob's cattle is a widely grown
traditional variety
whose specific origins are somewhat
unclear but that has a long history in
the northeast
and particularly in new england
so first traditional varieties offer
potentially useful traits for
diversification
and improvement of modern bean varieties
but have long been underutilized
this untapped potential has led to an
increase
in traditional and land raised variety
trials being conducted
both here in our breeding program and
other bean breeding programs in the
united states
as well as globally traditional
varieties are increasingly being
considered
for unique traits that may have been
overlooked in the past
including nitrogen fixing ability
yield under low input conditions novel
seed coat colors and patterns
and unique culinary qualities
to determine the suitability of
traditional varieties for modern bean
improvement
these varieties are increasingly the
subject of genetic diversity studies
such as this one by wilker at all
these studies indicate that heirloom
varieties do offer a potential source of
novel genetic diversity
not present in modern cultivars and also
offer potentially useful traits
particularly for breeding
in organic or low input systems
in the figure on the left we see that
heirloom varieties
span both gene pools and offer many
novel seed traits
that are not represented in modern
cultivars
as with modern cultivars heirloom beans
can typically be assigned to a single
center of origin
and or race as i had described
earlier in the background but some
varieties show evidence of gene pool
admixture
this is especially common among
traditional varieties of
europe oops in
the figure to the right here
the single red point in the center of
the principal component
plot show evidence of gene pool
admixture
interestingly that same variety also
showed
the highest nutri nitrogen fixation
ability
within heirloom germplasm evaluated in
the wilkers study
in results from variety trials conducted
on certified organic land by our program
in 2019 and 2020 i mean you see here
results from the 2019
trial higher values are represented
by a green background on the plot
as you can see some non-commercial
varieties such as candy
stardust and jacob's cattle gold
demonstrated yield performance as good
or better than the commercial cultivars
which are indicated by black boxes
this demonstrates potential for these
varieties to be grown successfully at a
commercial scale
as well as integrated into breeding
programs
these results align with similar other
similar trials
which show some traditional varieties to
be competitive with modern cultivars
and others that are not
so first it's probably a good idea to
define
what exactly an heirloom variety or in
this case heirloom bean
is um we also and i probably will refer
this
refer to this as a traditional variety
as well
and we can define this as a population
variety cultivated for many generations
with origins in land races formerly
released cultivars
or both and these variety trials that we
were conducting
in 2019 brought to the forefront a
question
given the obscure history of most
heirloom bean varieties
when incorporating this material into
trialing and breeding efforts
how much does seed source of that
variety matter
so that inspired this case study
and we hope to determine whether seed
source was associated with significant
genetic
or phenotypic divergence related to that
divergence
we also wanted to explore different
modes of germplasm conservation
namely comparing our formal germplasm
system
the grin collection to decentralized
informal seed saving
and selling networks and finally we hope
to determine what the source of genetic
diversity might have been in these seed
sources
so through a collaboration with seed
savers exchange which is a non-profit
with a long history
of stewarding heritage varieties and
connecting seed savers
we first identified diverse sources of
jacob's cattle
via their seed exchange listings which
are primarily listed
by home gardeners we also identified
other sources within bean seed saver
networks in new england
a potential secondary center for the
jacob's cattle bean
with roots in indigenous cultivation in
the region
finally we identified sources within
small
farm-based seed companies throughout the
north
northern sector of the united states as
well as
in nova scotia in general we attempted
to obtain seed sources that had been
grown in distinct environments
for a number of years
eighteen sources were ultimately
obtained and included in the study
originating primarily again in the
northern
portion of the united states and
southern canada
some have distinct strain names but were
generally generally defined
as being associated with jacob's cattle
some seed sources have been saved by a
single grower in a single location
for as many as 30 years and some for
much less time
we also obtain seed from five sources of
a commercial
kidney to serve as a check
and finally researchers at the
university of minnesota
shared unpublished sequence data from a
study of four
other heirloom bean varieties with 20
individuals from a single seed source
genotyped for each variety this data
allowed us to compare diversity with
single seed sources
within sources between jacob's cattle
and other heirloom varieties
providing valuable context for our data
and those are the strain names
okay four individual plants from each
seed source
or genotyped using genotyping by
sequencing or gbs
we obtained 150 base pair paired end
reads
using an apki digest the sequence data
was then pooled with the
university of minnesota data
thanks to dr tom michaels and dr hanna
sweegarden
and downstream analysis was conducted as
a single batch
reeds were aligned to the fascious
vulgaris genome version 2.1
snips were called in tassel and filtered
using vcf tools
filter parameters were five percent
minor allele frequency
maximum missing of sixty percent and a
depth range of three to thirty
population genetic analysis was done in
r using various
packages second field phenotyping was
conducted in summer 2020
we used an augmented design with four
blocks and two replications
data was collected on morphological
traits that are previously correlated
with genetic diversity
in common bean a secondary goal of
growing the seed sources
in a common garden experiment such as
this
was to harvest seed from all sources
bulk that seed and redistribute it back
to participating seed savers
that sent a seed which would increase
genetic variants
for each seed savers population and
allow for subsequent
selection and re-adaptation to their
environment
so diving right into results
a principal component analysis of
jacob's cattle seed sources
along with our single sources of those
four
other heirloom varieties and our
commercial checks
confirm the center of origin for the
heirloom varieties included in the study
and demonstrates genetic divergence of a
subset of jacob's cattle
seed sources so as with previous
principal components shown we see
typically principle component one
defining andean versus middle american
clusters quite clearly
so overall jacob's cattle sources shown
by green plus marks encircled in a black
circle
show more divergence along both
principal components
compared to other varieties with fewer
sources
including are five sources of the
commercial kidney
shown here by an orange triangle and
single sources
of four other heirloom bean varieties
single black and pintogenotypes
were included to contextualize gene pool
clustering
and so are shown towards the right of
the plot by a red circle
and purple crossed box respectively
we see that all heirloom varieties
included appeared to be of andean origin
with the exception of peregian which
appears to be of
middle american origin likely race
mesoamerica
to give some context for this
intravarietal divergence
some jacob's capital sources appear to
diverge more than distinct
varieties suggesting substantial genetic
variation between
sources in particular
one seed source circled in red
demonstrates relatively large divergence
across the principle
the first principle component which is
associated with gene pool assignment
so zooming into a principal component of
jacob's cattle seed sources only
we can see more clearly here that 14 of
those 18 sources circled in black
tightly cluster in the lower left of the
plot while four sources
show significant divergence one in
particular
circled in red that we noted in the last
plot shows a much higher divergence
across
principle component one than other
sources
next we conducted a discriminant
analysis of principal components to
assign genetic cluster to seed sourced
genetic data are first transformed using
principal component analysis
into components that explain most
genetic variation
these components are then used to
perform a linear discriminant analysis
which minimizes genetic variation within
populations
while maximizing among population
variation this method is useful in the
context of our case study
as it does not require assumptions of
hardy-weinberg or linkage disequilibrium
as a structure analysis does but is
still an effective tool for assigning
group membership
we conducted the discriminate analysis
using the addigenet package in r
goodness of fit was determined using a
bayes inference criteria
or bc resulting in k equals
five clusters fourteen of eighteen
sources formed a single cluster
with four other sources each comprising
a single distinct cluster these group
assignments were subsequently used to
analyze sequence data
as well as phenotypic data
both seed sources obtained from the grin
system clustered with a dominant group
3.
unique clusters each comprised of a
single seed source
came from diverse seed source types
with two sources from the seed savers
exchange network
one from a small commercial seed company
and one from a commercial farm in maine
out of these four sources three were
distributed under a distinct strain name
indicating that their stewards
recognized they diverged from a typical
jacob's cattle
so snips were distributed across all 11
chromosomes with some large distinct
tabula type blocks present
in a subset of assigned genetic groups
this figure plots minor alleles across
all 11 chromosomes with a sine genetic
group or cluster
on the y-axis each mark represents a
single genotype
at a given locus blue marks
denote a homozygous call of the minor
allele
while red marks denote a heterozygous
call
because 14 of 18 seed sources had
essentially the same genotype
blue marks can be thought of as
indicating locations at which
a certain genotype differed from that
that group of 14 highly homogeneous
sources
in this way we're treating the most
common haplotype at a given
locus as the reference genotype
so looking at the y-axis we see our five
assigned genetic clusters
four of these clusters consist of a
single seed source
and are denoted by yellow green blue and
purple bars
two sources display large haplotype
blocks within the reference background
while two others show smaller areas of
integration
interestingly many of these novel
haplotype blocks do not overlap between
sources
suggesting the occurrence of unique
outcrossing events
in several sources
here we zoom in to just those four
divergent seed sources
that comprise groups one two four and
five
and compare these data to our two
mesoamerican checks
a pinto and a black bean we see
substantial homology between some of
these seed sources and
middle american genotypes leading to the
conclusion that outcrossing
possibly occurred between jacob's cattle
and a middle american genotype
sources in particular groups four and
groups five
so large introduced haplotype blocks
which are homologous to the middle
american line
but not always with each other
suggesting potential
outcrossing or
subsequent divergent selection
in multiple instances or in separate
instances rather
because all sources maintained a seed
phenotype associated with jacob's cattle
this suggests that some selection
occurred after this outcrossing event to
regain a familiar seed
phenotype alternatively it's possible an
intentional cross could have been made
with subsequent selection following
and here we zoom in even further
comparing
our four distinct groups with our two
middle american checks
along chromosome 2 only and at this
resolution we can clearly see defined
haplotype blocks
denoted by the dotted lines that are
homologous
to our two middle american genotypes
in particular we can see slightly more
homology between the race durango
which is our pinto and groups four and
five
suggesting that perhaps the middle
american genotype
cross of these sources was a race
durango
so the second part of this case study
was to explore potential correlation
between genotypic and phenotypic markers
of diversity
this was explored using a field trial
with an augmented design
including two replications and four
blocks
five seed sources were replicated in all
four blocks
acting as checks traits measured were
stem length
number of nodes on the main stem number
of pods per plant
yield per plant and 100 seed weight
measurements were taken on four randomly
selected plants within each plot
at first glance differences in seed
phenotype were clearly apparent
across seed sources that were all grown
in the same field
in the same season indicating potential
for genetic basis
of the seed phenotypes
and when we match these photos to our
discriminate analysis plot
we see that these phenotypic
distinctions do seem to correlate to the
genetic cluster
further supporting a genetic basis for
phenotypic divergence
and diving into measured phenotypic
traits we also found significant
differences in mean trait values between
clusters this was especially pronounced
in 100
seed weight but was also apparent in
number of pods per plant
interestingly cluster 4 which is the
most genetically distinct cluster
in our principal component analysis show
shows a higher number of pods per plant
and a lower 100 seed weight
both of which would be expected in
genotypes with middle american ancestry
a second cluster group 5 also shows
significantly lower seed weight
these two groups were also those that
exhibited large
haplotype blocks in our snip
distribution and were most genetically
distinct
from other seed sources
we also see significant differences in
stem length
again group 4 shows longer stem length
which again is the expected phenotype
for a middle american germplasm
one genetic group also had significantly
lower yield than the other four groups
though reasons for that are unclear
and wider variance was also observed for
this trait
those results might be unsurprising
given the complex
nature and generally low heritability of
plant yield
compared to these other traits measured
so further supporting an association
between phenotypic traits
and genotype we see a high correlation
between 100 seed weight
plotted here on the y-axis and principal
component 1
of our principal component analysis of
jacob's cattle seed sources
for 100 seed weight and principal
component 1
the r-squared value was 0.6
as you might remember from previous
figures values for pc1 were highly
correlated to
gene genetic ancestry with higher pc
value
higher pc-1 values associated with
middle american genotypes
as mentioned before also lower seed
weight
and smaller seed size is also closely
linked
to middle american ancestry compared to
indian genotypes this indicates that
distinct seed sources
likely represent a cross between jacob's
cattle
and middle american germplasm and that
some seed sources
possess distinct phenotypic traits as
the result of that
crossing some correlation between other
phenotypic traits
and principal component one were was
observed
but with much lower r squared values
indicating a weaker causal link
so to summarize very low diversity was
observed within seed sources of jacob's
cattle
with the four individuals genotyped in
each source tightly clustering with each
other
this is meaningful in thinking about
institute germplasm stewardship
as each individual seed saver
participating in this project
would have had limited ability to adapt
their population to a given
environment due to low genetic variants
even over the span of 30 some years
we found that pooling multiple seed
sources of jacob's cattle
revealed significant levels of genetic
diversity
we hypothesized this diversity was
driven by several
several separate incidents of accidental
or intentional crossing
between jacob's cattle and another
genotype
followed by selection or perhaps roguing
to regain
elements of a jacob's cattle like
phenotype
this is significant as an outcasting
event of this type
would have increased genetic variance of
the population being stewarded
allowing for selection and adaptation
in that environment despite this
a majority of seed sources were highly
related
indicating that many nodes within seed
saver networks
might have had a relatively recent
common seed source
this is consistent with the relatively
nascent history of seed saving networks
in the united states states with groups
such as seed savers
acting as a central hub for traditional
germplasm
preservation and distribution
we also hypothesize that at least two
separate instances
of outcrossing of jacob's cattle with a
middle american genotype
might have occurred this is significant
as admixture between
gene pools is relatively uncommon in
modern bean cultivars
except in the instances of disease
introduction of specific traits such as
perhaps
disease resistance
substantial genetic diversity was
captured in sources from seed saving
networks
that would not have been captured by
sourcing this variety
from either a commercial seed source
only or formal germplasm repositories
this further indicates that
decentralized seed saving networks
might may offer an untapped source of
genetic diversity
and that trialling of heirloom varieties
should take into account
potential divergence of seed sources
and moving on i will now
drink some water first
and then discuss an applied breeding
project
to develop disease resistant specialty
dry beans
for regional food systems utilizing
traditional varieties as a source of
novel treats
so here in the northeast you may have
noticed that we have regular
precipitation
in the summer and fall and many of the
agronomic traits prioritized
for our region are related to that
challenge this includes a bush growth
habit that is
upright and holds pods off the ground
we are also challenged by a number of
foliar bacterial and fungal diseases
two of the most significant foliar
pathogens are xanthomonas campestris
faziolai causal agent of common
bacterial blight
and coletta trichome linda mucianum
causal agent
of anthracnose both of which can
severely decrease yields and are
transmitted
via infestation or infection of seed
bean common mosaic virus is less
frequently transmitted from plant to
plant
in a field setting here in the northeast
but it is commonly transmitted
in western production region regions by
aphids
where large outbreaks can occur even
with just a few infected plants
initially
since so much of our seed is produced in
the west and once a seed stock is
infected with this virus it is
virtually impossible to eradicate
resistance to this pathogen remains a
priority
so the first priority of the breeding
project was to improve
agronomic and disease resistance traits
the parent genotype that we chose based
on
preliminary trials and literature
reviews conferring
improved disease resistance and other
yield related traits such as plant
architecture
and maturity time was usdk
cbb 15 which is a usda developed
dark red kidney breeding line with good
agronomic performance
in our trials resistance to common
bacterial blight
and being common mosaic virus as well as
two resistance alleles
for anthracnose cbb-15 was developed via
marker assisted selection
for disease resistance but because this
resistance
is quantitative and only a small number
of genetic markers have been identified
direct disease selection was also used
to obtain
a resistant breeding line with the two
resistance loci sap6 and su-91
as well as likely other minor resistance
loci
because common blight was the most
problematic pathogen
in our trial and breeding plots and
resistance to this
disease is most complex selection for
resistance
was the primary focus of phenotypic
analysis
in contrast resistance to bcmv is
convert
conferred by the i gene which is an r
gene conferring
complete resistance under most
production conditions in the northeast
there are also several recessive alleles
for resistance to bcmv
but these were not targeted in the
current project and deployment is less
widespread
in contrast the igene is present in
nearly all modern cultiva
cultivars highlighting its importance
but as this resistance allele originates
in the middle american gene pool
it is unlikely that any traditional
varieties of indian origin
that are common in the northeast possess
this allele
resistance to anthracnose is typically
characterized by race-specific
qualitative resistance genes and cbv15
is thought to possess the co1 and co2
loci
in developing a bean that is compelling
to consumers and offers a high value for
farmers
clearly setting the bean apart from
commodity market classes
is important on the left we see some
examples of commodity market class beans
and their seed coat colors and patterns
all of those classes have a dominant
allele at the t locus
which gives them a solid color or
pattern
on the right you see some heirloom bean
varieties that all have a partial white
coloring
over a colored or patterned background
which is conferred by a recessive t
or tcf allele at the t locus
the figure in the middle outlines how
that recessive allele interacts with
some other seed coat genes
to produce diverse white patterns
on a self-colored background
so our two heirloom varieties were
calypso and jacob's cattle
which were selected because they are
already very widely grown
across the united states relative to
other
traditional varieties and perform
relatively well
in the northeast all of these parents
have a determinate bush habit
and are presumed to be of andean origin
from the race
nueva granada
as i alluded to those strides have been
made in improving resistance to
bacterial blight
current sources only confer partial
resistance
and this is particular particularly
challenging in
andean germplasm so four linked genetic
markers have been identified with 22
known major and minor effect loci
no resistance has been found in indian
germplasm
meaning that most heirloom beans of the
northeast and many modern kidney and
cranberry cultivars
are highly susceptible cbb15
has two major resistance loci as i
mentioned
as well as my other minor resistance
loci
in trials cbb15 showed more resistance
than a susceptible andean check
but less than middle american sources
indicating the difficulty of bringing
high levels of resistance from one gene
pool to another
so we use marker assisted pedigree
selection with the goal of introducing
disease resistance
traits associated with higher yield and
upright growth habit
into jacob's cattle and calypso
backgrounds
using cbb 15 as the donor parent
in the f2 through f4 generations
codominant snip markers were used to
screen seedlings for resistance loci
and those carrying one or more resistant
alleles were grown to maturity to
evaluate seed coat phenotype
in the f4 generation bulk leaf samples
from 34
families were genotyped rather than
individual plants with the goal of
selecting whole families for advancement
based on genotype and plot disease
phenotype
ratings
within the context of this breeding
project we're able to begin using high
res
resolution melt markers to screen
progeny
rather than gel based methods
streamlining the process and allowing
co-dominant
genotyping for resistance loci
this technique entails the design of
primers with gc rich tails of differing
lengths
that assign different
contrasting melting temperatures to each
allele at the locus of interest
um a simple pcr
is first run with a die followed by a
stepwise melting curve
protocol on a real-time pcr
this results in a figure as you see on
the right
which clearly shows homozygous or
heterozygous ileal calls
based on contrasting melting temperature
we are very grateful to the mickless lab
of the usda
for sharing this invaluable protocol
with us by the f4 generation in summer
of 2020 we obtained 17 families with the
desired
partial colored seed coat and at least
one resistance alleles
each locus some examples of f4c codes
show interesting divergence from
parental phenotypes
the result of recombination between
interacting seed coat genes
in 2020 we've phenotyped full civ
progeny rose
for disease incidents under natural
bacterial blight pressure
which we have easily obtained over both
field seasons
disease incidence was rated as a
percentage of leaf
area affected on a whole plot basis
on the left you see parent genotypes
with cpb 15
showing much lower disease incidence and
on the right you see
f4 families binned by
genotype we see a wide range of likely
susceptibility
within pooled genotypes which is which
would be consistent with the complex
nature
of bacterial blight resistance and with
past
studies we also see no additional
resistance conferred by the sapsis 6
locus
indicating that our endemic bacterial
blight strain
may be a more virulent one
so moving into the f4 f sorry f5
generation
we can begin to select families based on
direct disease
screening rather than just genetic
markers
so for example we could replant families
that exhibited
disease incidents equal to or lower than
our resistant parent
the following season
parent genotypes also diverge
substantially in plant architecture
with cbb15 possessing larger plant size
greater plant height greater number of
pods
per plant and longer maturity time
because jacob's cattle and calypso
generally exhibit
shorter maturity time than is needed for
our region
we selected four families that exhibited
architecture traits
more similar to cbb15
importantly longer maturity time is
often correlated to higher yields in
common being
so in summary this breeding work
breeding project
is definitely a work in progress however
successful introgression of several
disease resistance loci
including the eye gene for bcmv
resistance two loci for bacterial blight
resistance
and the co1 locus for anthracnose
resistance was achieved
though contingent selection for these
alleles will need
will be needed to achieve improved lines
possessing
all four resistance alleles
direct disease screens under natural
bacterial blade pressure
highlighted the complexity of resistance
to this pathogen
but some families promisingly show
comparable resistance
to the cbd parent future direct disease
screens could be improved by using
uniform inoculation trials rather than
natural disease pressure
as within field variation and pathogen
load
may have contributed to substantial
variation
in phenotypes one potential direction
for this material would be a multi-line
or mixture
approach by bulking advanced lines that
are fixer-enriched for resistance
alleles
and have enough uniformity to be
commercially viable
while maintaining enough diversity
diversity
to offer potential buffering effects in
the face
of environmental stress as yield
stability within pure cultivars is a
major challenge
this would be a significant advantage
and as a concluding note
we recognize the complexity of working
with traditional and indigenous
bean varieties in the context of a
university breeding program
and one reason for selecting traditional
varieties that are already widely grown
commercially
was to respect long-standing ties
between indigenous groups
in the northeast to be in varieties they
have stewarded and selected over many
centuries
for this reason we chose not to use rare
varieties that are still closely tied
to indigenous stewardship the use of
indigenous germplasm to develop new
intellectual property products is a
complicated question and is one that i
have personally
grappled with to some degree during this
project
and that's it i would like to offer many
thanks to my fellow lab members
for all their help my advisor michael my
committee
and other faculty have shared advice and
insights i'm also
very grateful to the public green dean
reading community
and their willingness to advise and
share germplasm especially dr phil
miglis
tom michaels hannah sweegarden
timothy porch travis parker and evan
wright
i am also very indebted to the many
growers processors and others
who generously offer their time to
letting me pick their brains about all
things
being related i would also like to thank
my funding sources through the usda nifa
and northeast sare
that wraps it up
thank you kristen for that that great
seminar um
if i know if anybody has any any
any questions uh for kristen she'll have
her
the defense immediately following this
so her committee might not have many but
i'd say you could either enter them in
the chat
uh or if you'd like to uh unmute
yourself
and ask it directly uh people should
have the
the ability or let us know in the chat
this may be to to kick things off chris
and so you you looked at
um jacob's cattle is a collection
that was in the northern us i didn't see
any below
new york uh could you elaborate on why
you
uh hadn't seemed to seem to have that
latitude cut off
yeah i i did try to
[Music]
find more sources in the southern part
of the country but
i think there's probably various factors
i mean certainly jacob's cattle
has strong cultural ties to
new england as i mentioned it's a pretty
short season
variety and in general
indian germplasm which of which it is
one
um tends to be better adapted to
in our country more northern regions
whereas we see more middle american
[Music]
heirlooms land races in
southern regions particularly in the
southwest
and i think there's also fewer seed
savers potentially you know there's a
lot of seed saving networks in more
northern parts of the country so
it's a little bit complicated perhaps
there's a question from uh jenny moore
in the chat ginny would you like to ask
it
yeah sure thanks um uh yeah i was just
wondering
um kind of about the um if there's
something unique about jacob's cattle
that makes it more diverse than other
heirlooms or if you would expect to see
kind of a similar
range of diversity um if you screened
you know similar number of sources of
some other heirloom
yeah that's a great question and
initially i should say that
we intended to do this with two
different
heirlooms and then had like a surprise
um doubling of our genotyping costs
after we made our budget so we did one
um but
yes i think jacob's cattle um
probably is more likely to
exhibit this pretty um significant
diversity between sources um
as i said yeah it's been cultivated
it's probably one of the most widely
cultivated varieties and i think that
has a lot to do with it
and it does have more um sort of
varying strain names compared to others
um so something like a yellow eye i bet
would show
similar um divergence but others that
haven't been
cultivated as white widely spread
are probably much less diverse
so
so uh kristin what's next with uh
these the the bean breeding line so you
you uh
you thought about you talked about them
as a participatory program
and kind of the next steps but what do
you see
as their their future in the world who
do you see
wanting to to grow them or how will they
uh
distribute market and how will they
appear to the public
home gardener packaged
i mean i think it depends on where we
end up with it
right i hope they
are productive enough to um
to serve a commercial market there's um
as i said i you know also did a lot of
just sort of talking
with people in the supply chain of
regional
um grains and related staple crops
and there there really is quite a lot of
consumer excitement
around um specialty traditional
varieties
um and so i think there's if you know if
we're able to have a
a good source of seed um
and what a you know
good performing variety for commercial
farm i think there definitely is a
market
for commercial production outside of
the predominant market classes cool
and then it'll be very appropriately
wonders about
flavor and taste you see there in the
chat
yeah yeah yeah yeah flavor and bean
i feel like it's this somewhat
controversial thing
and i think um i mean
definitely it would make sense to
evaluate flavor and
i think you know in the we were limited
by small seed quantity and the
generations that we
you know got through so far but
definitely once we had
the ability to have larger plots and
potentially grow the beans in different
locations
doing a tasting panel would
would be highly
recommended for sure
um yeah and i i mean i guess where i
land on that is i think often these
varieties have different culinary uses
rather than like certain ones being like
so delicious and others being gross um
they're sort of like are more suited for
different culinary applications
cool and i think there's uh time for one
more question i think from
uh courtney uh maybe i might paraphrase
so how might you
imagine this extending to other seed
networks or what can you envision
uh going on in other seed saving
networks in terms
of diversity kind of based on what you
saw
yeah i mean i see being as being sort of
like if diversity exists here
it probably exists everywhere because
bean is a highly self-pollinating crop
and like i mentioned these seed saver
networks
i mean this is sort of just an anecdotal
thing but
with these large seeded crops you know
tiny amounts of seed are shared between
these networks you know you'll maybe
pass on
five seeds and so it really discourages
maintenance of diversity so um and
i mean definitely other people have done
work in other crops
for example wheat and
it would be pretty different with a
cross pollinating crop but definitely
you would expect to see
you know increased diversity i would
expect
so yeah and sandra asked um
out of all the beautiful beans how did
you choose to work with jacob's cattle
specifically
and that was um in part due to the sort
of widespread cultivation
of it and that we were working with it
in our breeding program certainly played
a role um
also you know i formed collaborations
with
seed savers um including heron breen
who i somehow left out of my slide which
is horrible
who is very embedded in the main seed
saving networks
and and sort of um helped to to dream up
that project
so um it just sort of seemed like a good
a good starting point for exploring that
story that there might be
a story there with jacob's cattle
cool i think thanks for that all those
great great questions
uh it's a great way to follow up and i
think uh i think well
thank you again kristen for this uh uh
sharing all your research with us yep
and um
i think uh and if anybody wants to
follow up i think you'll know where to
find
uh divine kristin uh or some more
questions i think she'll stay uh in the
area uh
for a bit at least so um
yeah so i think we'll move on to
kristen's uh
uh defense uh after this but just uh
yeah thank you all for coming to
uh and uh uh kristen
great job thanks all thanks for coming
good to see ya
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu